minerals necessary if you have a good diet. It depends. So one would argue that our food,
even if we have a really good diet, doesn't contain the same amount of vitamins and minerals
that a good diet did 100 years ago. And I think you had some valid arguments. I mean, there's been tests
done on how many, how much vitamin C is in an orange, let's say, versus how much it was 100 years ago.
There is that data on some of the nutrients. And it is sad story because our soils are depleted
often. And even if we have a good diet, we maybe consume a lot of things that damage the gut
walls over that absorbing as many things. But so technically, no, you should be able to get
everything from your diet. But there's times where our body is under more stress, like minerals
are needed more in the summer because you're sweating out a lot of minerals. When you are outside
and you're working outside if you're sweating a lot, you're going to need more minerals.
Minerals are necessary for different things, especially magnesium. That's probably the
number one mineral efficiency. And magnesium deficiency can lead to all sorts of different issues.
It's necessary to probably find the 700 different metabolic functions in our body. It's a cofactor.
So it's something, you know, good minerals, it's not expensive either. So
so yes, it don't. I would say if you have a really great diet, maybe you don't need minerals
but it's different times of stress you do. So just be aware of that.